The panicked, worried, 'Do we need to get
out?', because I'd been checking Facebook
and there was lots of messages sitting there
saying, 'You know, is it a tsunami risk?'
and 'Do I actually need to get out?'
'Am I actually safe here?'
I was getting my car ready, just putting the
emergency stuff in the car, getting the dog
ready and then the sirens went, and we were
like, we might as well just go.
They were very, very loud here.
That night I guess, it was absolutely still and
the sound carried for ages, and I think maybe
that panicked a lot of people.
Definitely need to have them happen.
People didn't really know what to do.
We're close to the coast, but are we that
close that we need to get out?